Although typically View-port is only being set on Load, you can
actually play around with the View-port settings in the development tools
to tweak it, and get it just right. If I go
into the page and set the Viewport meta element contents from
the mobile dev tools It will change the page, as if
it had been refreshed, however, and this is where it gets
a bit confusing, the zoom level is maintained by the browser
across pager refreshes, so when you change viewport settings in the source
code, and you're reloading, be sure to actually close
the tab first. Don't just hit reload or it won't
necesarilly show the effects on the screen. For example,
let's go back to our last bit of code. And
change that width to something really different. Let's double
the width to 1832. And now let's save that to
the server and reload it on our mobile device. Our
new View-port setting doesn't take effect. On the other hand,
if we close the tab first and then reopen it, our new View-port
setting now takes effect. So pro tip, always remember to close the tab.